Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Increased.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Oh
Wow.
Mark
beyond the least.
Yeah.
Model.
Right?
Grazers.
Yes.
Frasier's bad.
It's good that it's,
it's boys saying it.
Gaping Dad.
Wow.
That song is called Bert is fat.
Um,
this
instrumental.
So that was great.
Gaping Dad.
Thank you.
Um,
this instrumental by Andrea Rella is called Burdis fat
and by way I just moments ago uploaded a new blog that deals with the entire
burden is fat phenomenon.
So it's on my personal youtube channel.
Please subscribe or prescribe to it.
Um,
and uh,
yeah,
it's the whole thing.
There's more layers to the story.
More layer to the store.
Yeah.
It's a police check it out for a Chrysler being.
How's it flappers last night in the kitchen and Burt's on their calendar,
they hand write in who's coming up on a dry erase board and it said Bert
Christ's nurse with an end.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I change it to Chrysler immediately,
of course.
All right.
Um,
great weekend by the way.
We have a lot to cover today.
Great.
Great weekend for me.
In a gas field.
Tennessee zaniest all five shows sold out.
Oh,
great crowds.
I had an absolute blast time.
I can't wait to hear about your IBSD update.
There's IBS stuff.
There's all kinds of updates man.
Um,
but thank you so much.
Josh Potter came out.
Thank you so much for making the trip.
Gosh,
pattern.
Yeah,
he's great.
So it was really,
really fun.
Um,
what else?
So this weekend wets west nut sack,
New York Ho uh,
that's a big,
big one for me.
You've been there.
I've been there.
It's fun.
You're going to love it.
All the reviews are in that mall too.
So that's a,
when people have been following up about that,
they've been talking and saying there is indeed.
I see big day.
Big Week for,
yeah,
it's a very big week for me.
You really get to enjoy that.
It's the full charge with you to the full charge.
Yes.
Oh,
you guys are going to enlist pancakes will have all kinds of stuff coming down.
Um,
here's my a calendar stuff.
Sorry,
I've got to pull it up.
July seven,
eight and nine births of Fatty Ohio.
It's a fatty.
Yeah.
I'm of the Cincinnati Fart Room.
Six one eight six one eight renaissance.
No.
Will you be doing a pilgrimage?
What you out your mind?
Of course going back there.
Um,
that is July seven,
eight nine July,
1415 16 man,
Diego,
California.
Um,
July 21st through 23rd taint poo ish,
Missouri.
Thanks true.
Saint Louis Louis August.
Uh,
I got Baltimore.
She's a whore.
Um,
that's actually,
uh,
what's it called?
Timonium Magoo.
Boobies.
August four,
five six and then come all over us.
Uh,
Ohio.
The funny bone that's also at August.
So please Tom [inaudible] dot com shows his to show his page and
you can get your tickets now.
Genes.
Genes this Wednesday,
June 22nd,
actually,
the day this drops 8:00 PM I am at the Hollywood improv.
September 27th big show by the way,
big show.
The big show.
I can't say why,
but I know,
but mommy's,
you should.
What?
You want to go to the show,
the show if he can and all rosy at about 8:00 PM show business guys show
business.
September 27th,
8:00 PM meet Ravel Washington.
How's that one good.
And to come on your comedy club one night.
Only one night.
Only September 20th but you're really into,
come on.
Yeah,
that's correct.
That is correct.
It's really going to come on.
Yeah.
It's not in me.
Rattle.
No.
September 28th uh,
Portland or Oregon.
Yeah.
Oregano.
Oregano at the hearing them comedy.
Kreb
oh boy.
That's a very inappropriate,
did not respect pronouns on that one.
Okay.
October 4th
that's Dallas.
DMIS eat my ass.
Dallas,
Texas at Hyenas Comedy Club.
One Room.
I fell off the stage here.
This is a club.
I fell off the stage.
Yeah.
I was coming down and my ankle twisted and I ate shit.
Yeah,
it was really fun.
I'm excited to go back again.
October 5th Houston.
Justin.
Yeah.
Tay House at the secret group,
whatever that is.
Yeah,
I know who that is.
Okay.
By the tickets at my website,
thousand ranch.com that's 1000 rand filling it out to t.
forgot to say http colon.
Slash slash.
Www.
Dad,
it can be very hard to figure this stuff out.
Are you guys made fun of me and blue bag cause I did it wrong in my,
was it Instagram or Twitter?
I did put a www and then what?
What did I do wrong?
You did everything wrong.
And my dad with my technology and it was all always,
we urge you,
please go to your mom's house,
podcast.com and shop through our Amazon banner.
When you do your Amazon shopping,
it's all the shopping you would do.
Oh yeah.
Just do it through our banner.
We get a little kickback.
It supports the show.
And did you know there's Amazon mom?
No.
Yeah,
you get discount on like mom products for babies and did you know on our
Facebook page,
on your mom's house Facebook page,
the fan page,
there's this like robot and mom page that everything we post it's like cool
post.
It's like your mom was like a mom thing.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
He's like great idea.
Like it's an automated thing.
So Tara,
really personal thank you.
And of course patriot.
I'll put that down.
patrion.com/mom the second bonus went up last week.
There's different tiers of support.
If you do the $5
Tier,
you get the bonus episode.
Yeah.
You get bonus episodes,
so,
right.
Yeah.
You get the most upset.
Okay.
Are you on now?
Yes.
Okay.
Hello?
Is it is a bird?
It's the wrong one.
Maybe about there.
Hey.
No,
no,
no.
That works.
Yeah.
Hey,
what?
His beak is touching the thing.
That must be why no fucking bird.
All right.
Anyways.
Um,
yeah.
$5 gets you bumps episodes on patriarchy.
There you go.
patrion.com/bob put that down.
You ready to start the show?
Let's do it.
Oh boy.
You wait a minute,
Michelle.
Oh boy.
Shaolin off again.
Huh?
Thirsty.
I'm the water champion.
Don't bring it
to your mom.
So
Christina.
Okay,
I got your own water.
Hold on.
I know you're reaching
or my water,
but I brought you a more appropriate size water have for your water intake.
You had to use both hands like Ellis does.
Is that good?
It's nice and warm.
It's from the sink.
It's tap water.
Jesus,
you jerk.
You couldn't even give me regular water here up.
I'll put the good stuff in there for it.
Yeah.
You kind of drank a lot of that.
You must not have been drinking that much this morning.
No,
I'm uh,
I'm drinking coffee right now.
You know why?
Because I'm super tired from drinking so much water.
Sure.
What color was your p this morning?
You're finished your city.
It was so clear that like trans,
it was just transparent,
whatever.
You don't even know this yet.
I haven't told you,
but yeah,
I installed this thing we got is called the the bowl glow.
That's a stupid little device you put in the toilet and it lights up the water
at night so you can see the toilet.
It can be any color.
Red,
blue,
green.
That's what that thing is.
Yeah.
So I was thinking how fun it would be if it's like,
you know,
if it's blue and then you make the water green with you,
it's going to be like a dark green.
No,
no.
With Neil stay blue.
Yeah.
It'll be like,
oh,
it's clear.
It doesn't even turn into anything.
I should have made it red.
That's normally what you see today.
This weekend with water.
With fitness actually.
Yeah.
Really?
No Sir.
I don't worry about it.
Okay.
Well I landed and Gosh,
Ceville Nashville,
Tennessee.
Uh,
I worked out every day.
They're good for you Thursday?
I did.
Uh,
what did I do?
I did both.
It was split day,
so I did like cardio and weights.
Friday only weights and Saturday cardio.
Wow.
I did it like two hours before my shows so I could work out.
Then you shower,
you little something,
go to the show and I just drank just ridiculous amounts of water.
Plus it was hot as fuck.
That'll make you drink a lot of water.
It's true.
I did.
I drank a lot of water this week.
Wow.
Good for you.
See that.
That's like a notable thing for you because I drink water all the time and I got
up
every morning.
I wake up at 5:00 AM before the kid wakes up and I hit the weights.
Even see me down there in the garage because I heard you say massage for my 40th
birthday,
my BFF Shauna came and we went to Bark Williams.
Happy Smurf Day.
21 years old.
You went to Burke Williams did everything to do with that.
She says,
you know,
thank you for my mom's side and they tag on my nails and my toes and they,
they go,
now you're gonna want to hydrate Africa toxin.
But the lady,
when she whispered in my ear,
her breath was really bad.
I'm a serious.
Did she go,
he'll probably want to drink a little more cause I can tell you
no,
but then she goes,
you're my favorite.
No Shit.
Then she kissed me on the floor.
No,
she did.
They don't do that for you there.
Yeah,
but I thought I was their favorite.
So she actually went,
she went
and her breasts dog so bad.
I know.
Don't whisper in my ear if you're breastfeeding,
that's brutal.
You know,
I just did an Uber ride with a driver whose breath wafted over across,
you know,
the console is like Jesus,
man.
Get your entire life.
Now this piece of shit video you made,
I saw an Instagram or are you threatening me with,
you're like,
oh,
I drank more than just a reminder that I'm the water champion.
I flew to Nashville sitting next to R and B legend Jill Scott,
by the way.
So my black celebrity status continues.
Yeah,
that's neat.
I told her about it about that.
That was like,
when I hear my list,
she goes,
yes,
we talked like most of the flight and she,
she goes,
yeah,
I go,
so I list her,
but she of course,
most impressed by Tyson.
That is that.
That's a good yet.
I go,
you're on the list now.
And she was like,
okay,
now do you have a funny story with her?
She was so lovely and just like just,
she's a poet and a,
you know,
she just talks about being centered and balanced and happy and not needing
everything to feel happy and like,
wow,
that's fair.
Very fun call.
She was very cool.
No,
you issued a little video statements saying that you drink more water.
I have a retort.
I'd like to finally make an official retort.
You've been a tag and make you this with you.
Did you guys work on this together?
It feels,
I know,
but I'm telling you that I am sick of the attacks on social media.
And finally this video will prove who is the real water drinking champion.
Just remember I,
okay.
Schnitzel.
Cause she's saying she,
she's a glass of water rights,
which makes the most of the water.
She's got her little,
her little hamster feed her in her cage.
I'm a little concerned about this.
Should I set this up?
This is going to definitively answer who's the more drinker of the waters in
this house?
Which one is it looks like there's two in here.
Oh it says three 49 underscore video or three 48 underscore water underscore
drinking.
Uh,
three 49.
Yeah,
three frame.
Okay.
Just so you know.
So we're doing this.
Just see,
should I set it up a little bit?
Can you tell me,
well Tom,
I decided to surveil your actual water drinking habits.
What?
Yeah,
I have footage from the last episode of Your Mom's house and let's see who
really drank more water.
Oh man,
you're so dead.
It was so dead with my weight.
My response videos absolutely massacre you.
Well,
let's see who drank more water and the last episode of Your Mom's house.
Kelly?
Yes.
What is she?
Parking?
Brake marking and our video.
Okay.
Hmm.
How has music?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Which mommy drinks more water?
Has what?
It says there is me.
I got one so far drinking the first time.
There's that one.
I got two,
two times.
I got three.
Tom's one right now.
Alright.
He's got to,
I can already tell you the floor and your video
got three.
I've got four.
Can I tell you the flaw in that?
There's no fraud drinking so much more than you.
You can tell.
You're really going to contest.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You can tell like yours,
just like,
like,
like you're just like a bitsy sit like and I'm like blah,
blah,
blah.
Yeah.
Whatever.
The record shop.
I'm at five,
five times drinking.
You're only a three.
You're four,
six,
four,
seven.
I'm at seven and we're still at four.
Oh,
I'm an eight.
And you're still at four.
I've
with what you drank on the last episode.
I drank doubling.
It's an old song on the record
so that was blue man.
Thank you man for making that second.
I drink double what you drank on the last episode.
Secondly,
first of all,
I mean people,
I feel like they can see this and they can see them in the population.
That was honest.
I just asked him after the episode,
why don't you put it together?
But I had an empty like 16 ounce bottle and that you had a still like half full
abi where you're like not well not sure cause I had to Amy on look at the backup
water to go with my primary.
There's overwhelming online support.
I'm a lot of champion.
Yes there is.
I've been getting,
a lot of people are just like I taught look at any posts down,
Instagram,
Twitter.
They're like,
clearly Tom's the water champ.
Yeah,
that is so false.
If you look in my car,
just go down to my car.
There's empty water bottles,
half bottles.
I hydrate constantly.
I just knocked down that sippy cup like it was nothing.
That is nothing.
It's a baby baby cat up dummy.
That's so stupid and it's so wrong.
You just got a water changes,
got molded and your booty exploded.
Here we go.
Well where's your water for it today?
It's here right now.
Okay.
Whenever
that's the point.
That's a sip for me.
Well you're except for me is a fucking pint and the sip for you is like,
like a little baby step or a bear.
You are drink way more water.
Five times my size and he'd drink five times less.
You're hydrated.
Inferior.
Hydrated fairy.
Yes.
Your age to know.
Wow.
I'm age too.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Wow.
So I just want to make it clear that video is dog shit
and you're the dog shit.
You're the water winter in the same sense that if I were to play basketball with
our son right now,
I'd be like,
you're the winner too.
You know,
I just put it in the basket mad because I burned you so good.
It's so,
so offensive.
Moded and your booty exploded all over this water place.
Okay,
we'll see.
Yeah,
we'll do a live contest coming up.
Legit.
It's already been done.
You want to talk about what happened?
A burns fat.
We can go there.
What did,
what did you want to talk about though?
Nashville.
Oh,
right.
So you,
you've met several celebrities in your life.
You've met your,
your Jill Scott.
Yup.
And that was awesome.
You sat next to her and then you met another
celebrity.
By the way,
a bunch of the titans came out and Tennessee titans,
football players,
a current and former really nice guys,
um,
hung out with them.
So shout out to the titans.
Um,
yeah,
so you're never going to believe this will you will now.
But I think a lot of our audience will be blown away by this.
Um,
throat Zilla came to a show Saturday.
It was unexpected.
I,
I've seen her posts and things like,
when are you doing a show here?
And I've just,
you know,
never,
it never occurred to me that,
that she wouldn't,
I saw a couple of posts that she said,
I'm coming to Nashville,
but you never,
you know,
people post things on your wall and you're like,
okay.
Yeah.
Um,
she bought a ticket.
She showed up and uh,
she wore a shirt that said throat Zilla on it and then Google me.
I'm so hoping somebody there,
it was like,
I wonder what that means is it picks up their phone like Google.
Whoa.
Yeah.
She DMD me on Twitter.
Like I'm going to see your man wants his shirt size and yes.
And then he's,
she's like,
there's too many people in line.
Oh,
really?
You meet your husband?
I was like,
what?
Wait though.
The woman who sucks Dick's professionally is like,
it's too hard to see.
That's fine.
Maybe you shouldn't be damning.
The wife I bought that throws with that.
How,
how uh,
pure her intention.
No,
I know.
I believe that.
Yeah.
But the funniest thing was that Friday I'm out with my friend Mike and his wife
and I'd only briefly met his wife.
So now we're having dinner after the show.
And I actually,
since I'm just getting to know her,
I go,
how'd you guys meet?
And as she's telling me,
and that's usually a story that you're paying attention.
You're pretty engaged.
My phone's lighting up and it's you.
Yeah.
So I just go like,
you know,
he's kind of look real quick and it says,
are you and your friends getting blown by throat Zillow right now?
And so I gotta I gotta I gotta answer this right?
Yeah.
So I tie it back to you like,
of course.
Yeah.
We're all,
we're all doing that.
Whatever.
No,
and then she's continued with the story and then the phone lights up again and
it's,
it's you.
Yeah.
And I keep going,
so I have to go.
I'm sorry too.
I'm not trying to be rude here.
Um,
but I think I got to call my wife.
She's like,
she goes,
no,
of course it's your wife,
like color.
She has no idea what we talk about.
So I tried to call you,
but of course we have no reception here.
Yeah.
So I have to keep texting you.
And then when I finally feel like,
cause don't,
you know,
with texts,
she actually had a good suggestion.
She's like,
I go,
I can't tell what she's joking.
You know sometimes when we joke she goes,
you're going to have like an Emoji that's code for a joke.
I'm like,
that's a,
that's a
serious or not serious.
If I use emojis generally and the text exchange it means I'm no,
but what if you had one that meant this is,
but just so you know,
generally if I'm using emojis it means I'm not really mad.
True.
So here is,
here's the exchange.
I go,
no,
she's not.
There you go.
Oh good.
I'm so happy.
My,
the blowjob lady is BFFs with my husband.
So I'm like pay.
Yeah.
Hopefully she'll be getting ready for Josh with me.
And then you go,
how did this come about that she was making the trip to see a nice trip to man.
I told this to Josh.
I've never seen him laugh so hard.
You Go,
great.
So can I become friends with the pussy eating machine guy?
And I go,
we are not friends.
And then you did put a bunch of emojis in eye rolling and one of the family
Emoji.
Yeah.
Like remember your family,
please remember your family
and your two dogs.
Emoticons for dogs and for our child together.
And you go,
please don't ruin our lives.
Like Babe,
you're killing me.
And then you sent me a picture of you and our son.
Well the best part was this,
that whole exchange then led to,
I'm really likes this guy.
Know that whole exchange then led to me coming back to the table and of course
everything all right.
And I go,
Oh yeah,
you know,
my wife was just joking but I didn't know.
She was like,
oh she's,
she makes a suggestion.
I go,
yeah,
this is this whole throat Zillow thing.
Like I'm sorry.
So then I'm laying out the details of who throws Zilla is and I can see her face
is like,
that's cool.
And I'm like realizing that our level of appropriate honor talk normal's a
little skewed.
Yeah.
Especially for first time didn't like normal people.
The Blow Job Queen,
you know.
So
anyways,
they were,
they were very nice people,
but I think I was horrified her,
but oh and throw Sheila was very nice.
Yeah,
I know.
She has.
How I finally got you to calm down.
I was like,
baby,
calm down.
I go telling,
you know you go,
come on man.
I go,
well first of all I'm going to have $400 on me.
And you're like,
oh,
okay.
I'm like,
he could have led with that that I don't have hundreds of dollars,
hundreds of dollars to spend on blowjobs.
Gosh,
no,
I did have my fingers crossed for Josh to,
I'll be honest with you.
I actually did as well.
So what did she
need Josh to or know what is is separation of church and state.
She was out for a night of just comedy and having gray.
She was off.
She was off the clock,
so to speak.
This was when she met him and she was like,
oh,
hi,
nice to meet you.
Like she was just nice and sweet lady.
Very nice.
And it's what an exciting thing.
Josh was kind of excited.
He was like,
hello.
He knew it was Josh,
by the way.
He's the one who introduced the whole story.
He started this again at Virginia Beach with,
I told her,
I go,
Josh is the one maybe maybe reward them,
you know?
And she was like,
she just said goodbye and left.
But she sounded sweet actually.
She was very nice.
Yeah.
I saw the picture of you two together and somebody saw the back of her head
picture somebody,
somebody goes,
uh,
did you give her,
did she give you the throat?
And she posted,
oh,
I could never do that.
I love his wife.
Aw,
that's sweet.
You're BFFs with throat.
We,
we DM each other.
It's really gave me your shirt size.
Yeah.
I was supposed to get my own church.
Said I should tell her your size.
So anyways.
Well good.
I'm glad to hear that your marriage is,
your valves are solo taxonomy are still intact.
Yeah.
Maybe we'll get Josh potter a Bj.
That's the goal.
Yeah.
What do you think it would take?
I mean it probably would take those hundreds and hundreds of dollars.
My whole thing is how disposable is your income?
I mean if I was making five,
$10 million a year,
think that's well worth the entertainment.
Sure is,
hey,
here's whatever your fee is please.
And then do we make them snap chat it to you?
Uh,
you know,
do we make it public or I wonder if he would sign up for that.
That's what I'm saying.
Like you can't just get something for nothing.
Josh,
if we get this for you,
you need to,
well as long as they give us a play by play afterwards of how should we do a
Kickstarter for Josh?
He did say though,
he goes,
cause we've seen some of her online footage and it's with let's just say large
individuals.
He goes,
what would she do with me?
Just kind of leaned forward and it would all be gone.
Oh I told her,
I asked her to do that for that video.
I go,
so then can you go pop,
pop,
pop.
And she goes,
that's not what it sounds like.
She did her own,
she was like,
she did it.
There was all kinds of people in the room and they were like,
wow,
that sounds way more authentic than Tom's version.
She's a professional experienced.
Yeah.
That's professional.
Baghdad professional man.
So big,
big celebrity week for you.
Big Celebrity Week.
Um,
Jill Scott and throwed Zillow.
So hilarious.
So
Smash Ceville.
Yup.
And give us an IBS update.
Did you really?
Interesting.
You know what's so interesting to sometimes you have explosive diarrhea,
like I do a couple of times a and you'll go,
oh it's,
you know what I just ate.
Must cause it.
And you go that's too rich or something.
And then just kind of not on your mind the next day
have a cheeseburger
and later you have a totally normal bowel movement.
Oh it is.
I be like Joe,
that is IBS.
Yeah.
I mean that's from what I have.
Why would that be IBM?
Because it is random.
It could be like a spasmatic a bowel thing.
So it is kind of arbitrary so that that could be part of it.
I don't know.
Okay.
What was the one going to a specialist?
Yeah.
When are you,
when is that appointment is coming up?
Let's put that on the calendar.
What?
What does blue band laughing?
I don't know.
I think he's just laughing that I have an appointment.
Maybe it take him along with you in video it?
No,
maybe not.
When is that appointment?
Jesus.
What is today?
20th okay,
so I have,
I have some appointment tomorrow,
but that's not it.
Oh,
it's the 30th good.
Okay.
The 30th I am keeping kind of a food diary so that you can tell the doctor after
I eat certain this and that.
It's a good idea.
I think that's what they're going to make you do.
Right.
So I'll do that.
I know Tempura makes you whenever we get like a fried food.
Yeah,
he shit right away.
Yeah.
Vegetables make you shit a lot.
Yup.
Pretty much everything makes you share.
No,
you say that and that's not true.
You Shit from Turkey.
Sketti I made that upsets your stomach too.
I didn't have Rhea.
Hmm?
No,
just the normal a blaster.
just that's like a normal thumb.
Yeah.
I mean what was this morning?
He's like,
it was a little hot,
but nothing.
You went out in a panic.
We were putting LJ down for his nap and you are like,
I got a shit.
No it wasn't.
I was like,
give me the baby,
don't,
well I think it was,
I was sitting with him once I stood up,
it was like I still had to go.
But sitting down.
Yeah.
It was the first coffee of the day.
It was ready to go.
You know,
it was kind of hot.
So,
but in Nashville,
what did you get to eat?
Ribs?
Cause that's a big,
no,
I didn't,
I didn't do anything crazy.
I mean you know how it is.
You always think you're going to do something like that,
but if you don't really make the effort,
like I was wanting to go to Hattie B's there,
which is like the hot chicken place.
There's a line around the block.
I never feel like doing that ever.
No matter how good it is.
If they're like,
yeah,
then you just wait in line for 45 minutes.
No,
fuck,
I'm Gail.
I agree.
I go down the street to the other place I went to,
I went to a good breakfast place.
Um,
what else did I do?
Pretty much hit man.
I ate at the hotel once,
um,
went out to eat.
We sit in smash bill.
We did that [inaudible] together.
We brought the fif even that,
that was a few years ago.
When was that?
Not that long ago.
Maybe.
Maybe two years.
Yeah.
And we stayed in some cool place downtown and there is that fancy
restaurant across the street in the hotel that you like to remember that.
Yup.
Yup,
I hate that shit.
Where they're like,
let's go to this famous a waffle place for breakfast.
And you're like,
great,
I'm starving.
And then you get there and they're like,
yeah,
that's another 40 minutes.
And you're like,
but I'm already fucking hungry.
Then you got to stand there and everybody are watching and patiently is
everybody gets seated and then by the time you sit down,
you're freaking out.
Um,
worst.
By the way,
I love these,
these weird Midwest and southern,
uh,
calling contest.
So they have,
oh,
right.
We've had the mom calling contest.
Yeah.
It's silly.
So this is a hog calling contest?
Yes.
Uh,
it's so bizarre man.
It is a whole art form.
Yeah.
Kris Carr.
More Eleanor.
Look how many motherfuckers are watching.
That's the crazy part.
Yeah.
Piggy,
piggy,
piggy.
Gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme
Bert,
Kris Carr.
Oh Wow.
That's weird.
Um,
what happened?
You're not going to watch the other one.
Yeah.
And there's,
there's different files.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Yeah,
that was good one.
So that guy,
he also had a corn cob on his head.
Sure.
Um,
so these people really do spend their days calling piglet.
I didn't know,
like,
I don't,
I don't know why you can't just call a pig the way you would the dog suit.
I like this one.
Come on.
This is how you talk to me.
Is that it?
Oh
wait,
you didn't get the rest of his,
uh,
what are you serious?
Jesus,
man,
you could just go to the original.
Holy Shit.
That's the whole thing is so good at it.
Lubin he was the best.
Yeah.
Like I really any kind of looks like a pig to super fat a,
but he's,
no,
we should just,
instead of calling people fat wishes,
call him Bert like I Super Bert.
You know Jesus.
Okay.
It's a pretty intense feeling.
So Burt today.
Yeah.
You really are.
Oh,
did he make,
he made a video about you too?
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
We got to get to that one is a
Kris Carr,
Illinois
there go.
Yeah.
Pinky.
Oh,
good.
Brushed it.
You murdered that shit,
Bro.
Drop the mic after that.
That Lloyd Christmas here.
I can actually,
yeah.
I'm actually,
I actually studied this and washed it and washed it,
so,
okay.
We'll see how well I do today.
Okay.
We will one week
you call yourself a big color.
Su,
Su
big,
big.
He's never really called a peg.
Does that really get them to come to you?
Got It.
Okay.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
Okay.
Nailed that shit.
Thank you.
His big mistake too.
You don't want to go to the same,
like I'm from the city folk.
You don't qualify what you're doing.
Just I can do it.
Yeah.
They'll make excuses.
Country of Shit.
Can you see us?
Yeah.
We don't want to hear about you city folk.
We're country is shit.
Yeah.
This is the Illinois.
Well,
there's an actual big
guys.
Don't fat.
Shame me.
Birch.
Shame with long hair right there.
She doesn't know.
Sure.
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh my God.
Jesus Christ.
They shouldn't assume Wacko.
Crazy.
Two birds tied together.
That's not even a pay college she's doing.
That's awesome.
I think
interpretive level.
Look how uncomfortable that she's like,
um,
that wasn't a pig call.
That was something else.
They're all looking at each other late.
I'd check.
What's crazy is that she comes to bed.
Wow.
Now we got to decide,
right?
Yeah.
Oh,
do you know who wins?
I think that lady does.
Really?
What?
Oh,
bullshit.
She sucked compared to a home.
Maybe that guy doesn't know that fat guy was,
uh,
the second guy was getting the sunglasses.
That was amazed.
This is crazy.
That's that.
This is the area you're calling champion this year is Kyle Barnes.
All right.
It was
hell to the no.
Oh,
this is fame from Des Moines,
Iowa.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm a Newbie here at the Illinois State Fair.
I have actually won the Iowa State Fair three times.
I'm the reigning champion over there and I was going to try the yard pig calling
trifecta.
Okay.
Yeah.
Sucks.
Nobody likes you.
Did not the champion and he's not the chair.
Not In your mom's house.
You're not as big boy with the sunglass.
Yeah.
By a mile.
Like I really killed it.
Yeah.
You know what it is?
I think they were sold by his hand gestures.
They liked that he,
his,
he added a little more flair.
Yeah.
And he went up with that.
I want to do it.
You sound like you almost ready.
I liked the,
uh,
that was good.
By really good at in practice.
That was my first time.
But that,
that shriek,
that sounds genuine.
Piggish you don't talk when they do the like,
yeah.
That thing.
That is so good.
I am even,
wow.
Maybe on the master of the closing,
my eyes go for it.
Burt Holman was super fat.
She's so big.
That was alarming.
Yeah.
Like you couldn't even see her chin.
Oh,
by the way,
my father texted me.
Yeah.
Got To tell you this a few days ago,
and he texts me that I put it on.
Um,
I put it on Instagram.
He goes,
I'm in the Orlando Airport
and I'm
shitting in the store that I shat in 18 years.
Wow.
So I wanted to see if we can get them on the phone.
Geez.
Let's see.
In the Orlando Airport
and his Chin is on the,
the outlet,
like the courts
hours,
Ponce.
Say Fifo.
Take a picture.
Hey Dad.
Hey Buddy.
How you doing?
Good man.
How's it going?
Do you want to be great?
Just don't forget to tell him right now.
Yeah,
I'm happy.
Father's Day.
Of course.
Again,
I hope you had a good one here.
I hear.
Yeah,
I did.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I'm going to ask you,
you,
uh,
texted me the other day that you went to the Orlando Airport
and Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You ended up kind of a notch
in the same store where I did my,
my famous shit.
Um,
I'm 19 years ago.
This was the shit that went through your
yeah,
yeah.
This is the one where I leave my underwear in the,
in the place and kind of just do the best I could with Nigel housers.
Amanda get on the plane.
I was in a brown spot in the cracker,
you know,
so this was the Yak stall.
So that was kind of it.
It ended up being kind of a nostalgic moment,
if you know what I mean.
You know,
you get emotional about it,
you know.
Well,
you know,
I mean get emotional,
but you know,
I,
this is one of the challenges that you face in life and you have to,
you know,
I mean,
I actually thought about adding to go home,
but I got it out and made my flight and you know,
got engine the new place.
Right.
So where were you flying to?
Do you remember?
Well,
uh,
I was flying to,
I think I was trying to Arizona,
so I was just like,
oh wow.
So you cross country with Dukie on your pants.
That's not too,
yeah,
Yup,
Yup.
Um,
wow.
That's pretty,
that's pretty neat.
It'd be Kinda cool if you also were to go to the same gas station in Miami that
you pulled over for your biggest shit ever.
Do you remember that one?
You know,
at that place she still existed today.
It would be a nurse.
I know.
Really.
You know that,
that we're talking by Miami's damage,
you know,
say kind of place where,
on the side you had transmissions.
I just discarded on the side.
Oh
Wow.
Do you remember,
did you finish that shit?
Did you tell him I'm about it at all or no?
Cause it was so epic?
Probably.
Yeah.
Do you think she probably enjoyed that or no?
Definitely not.
Um,
you know,
I was the one that we've been getting a lot,
a lot of people emailing us about double pipe classics,
you know?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They were,
you know,
they're very rare.
Yeah.
When I had my last one,
you know,
you,
you can go a whole year or two without even have her.
Yeah.
I mean,
Christina had her first one this year,
I think the first one in ages and I haven't had one this year.
I haven't handled it this year either.
Yeah.
That's the thing is,
and people are keep trying to,
they keep trying to manufacture them and I tried to encourage them.
You
can't,
you can't do it.
Yeah.
Just one of those things.
You know,
it's one of those things you just,
you got to let it happen.
Right.
Like you can't make it rain,
you know,
there's certain thing.
Right.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I remember the last time,
time
it rain.
That's true.
Yeah.
I mean,
cause then people will be like,
Hey,
um,
I sneezed and fired at the same time.
Does that count?
And I'm like,
no,
of course not.
No.
The GG to do that.
Exactly.
You know,
it's not special,
you know,
and uh,
and still not won yet.
Sorry to the shame.
So I know that,
you know,
in this round you just want to be judged.
Yeah.
I mean,
you gotta think about music though.
The reason it's so rare too is that you got air coming out of both ends.
You know,
usually,
usually it takes a,
it picks a road,
you know,
it doesn't actually go down both.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
You know,
I was like getting punched in the gut and it goes both ways.
Yeah.
It's really,
it's really something.
So
I don't remember the last time I had one of those,
you know,
I haven't had one that I would really remember it.
I'm pretty good about my classic moments about,
can't take it this way.
Wow.
Just shows you that you as the master an even you don't even recall your lap.
I remember having one,
I believe.
I mean,
we can probably find it in our show a year ago and it's,
you know,
for me,
probably maybe the third or fourth ever.
Very rare.
They're so rare and um,
yeah,
every time though,
it's a really special moment.
A lot of people have let us know about their first time and they're like,
oh,
it happened to me today is really spectacular.
Well,
yeah,
as Yogi Berra used,
just say,
you know,
there's only one the first time.
The first time.
Right,
right,
right.
That's true.
Um,
so have your,
um,
you know,
I'm going to go see a specialist actually because I have so many catastrophic
shits that I'm actually going to go check my guts out.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know that I have anything medical for sure,
but,
um,
I just figured,
you know,
I could just check it out,
see if any maybe food allergies.
It'd be my career all over again.
I'd really want to be a gastroenterologist.
Oh yeah.
You were made for it.
Yes.
If fascinates me,
Ron insider and the guts.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I checked her Nana,
I got,
I'm trying to say I took an antibiotic and as an antibiotic I've never taken
before.
Well,
I had the hardest shift gears.
Okay.
Really?
I May,
we're talking,
we're talking one GS and twosies.
Okay.
How long ago was this?
Just two weeks ago.
Oh really?
Cause I remember,
was it last year when you had the real hard shifts and we talked about
hydrating.
Yeah.
But this is really due to the antibiotic.
So I loaded up on metamucil and the center,
so that makes a difference.
Once I quit,
I quit the antibiotic.
I knew I was out of the Claire and I had my normal smarts smell a certain right.
You know,
I know.
Smells a certain way.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
And,
and that was like the ghost state know.
And sure enough later that day back to normal.
Wow.
What a neat story.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She had a price.
They little with that bacteria in your gut.
All right.
That's what they do.
They acknowledge Shoba your germs for you or what's wrong with you.
But they also getting a gut and,
and uh,
oh,
I have to tell you this.
Okay.
I was having lunch with a doctor.
It was like 85 and I don't know if you've ever heard what's called C diff.
It's a bacterial infection that is really a result of taking too many
antibiotics.
Okay.
Very common in nursing homes.
And today was people just take too many antibiotics.
You going to get to get all right.
Well you know a lot of people they say take probiotics and all this stuff,
but the,
what they really need to do is introduce a shit back into your gut.
In the old days they used to give you shit animals.
They would give you an animal of somebody else's shit
into your gut in order to reintroduce.
That's very,
what about just doing,
I never,
well you know I,
I'm sure that somebody might want to do that for fem or I was just fascinated by
it.
Yeah.
That is interesting
to do that or no,
no,
I never knew that until here earlier this year when I was having lunch with this
doctorate.
Wow.
Shit.
Anima.
What's the
C diff?
Yeah.
Wait,
spell it.
D.
I.
F.
C.
Oh by the way,
speaking of shirts.
How about your bedspread?
Th is everything cool with that now?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
That is cool.
Cause you shit on it.
I did
find or good to go.
Yeah.
It really,
I tell you,
you got to adjust a lot of room and the washing it only do one thing and the
washer and then the dryer and you know,
it's a lot of work to do also a badge for that.
But I'm sorry.
Yeah,
you're fine,
Huh?
Okay.
And the best friends.
Fine.
Yeah.
Once you do,
as if you're by yourself.
I was by myself and I did this,
you know,
you just take that with the shitty party.
You this kind of folds up the other way so it doesn't get idea.
Jay,
can you just sleep
right then?
You wash it right away,
you know,
I think I did it the next day.
It's already the truth.
My Dad,
she wants from you slept in a,
in a shit filled bedspread.
Yeah.
That's barbaric man.
I know,
I know.
Yeah.
It's your own stop.
So who cares,
right.
Kay.
Ah,
I do.
I think I would probably get up.
It's really,
that's a really savage,
I own my own brand and it doesn't bother me that much.
Okay.
Um,
Jesus man.
So you just,
Oh,
you hung up.
I guess how he did it.
I bet this face,
yes.
I bet you he did.
He mashed his face.
It was will be the first thing he said.
I hung up by you.
My face in it.
Hey Buddy.
Yeah man.
He believed that and I can,
it's a little like the room eight oh eight rooms.
Six one eight revelation.
Yeah.
He told us one story and it actually was another story
early.
Interesting.
Really interesting.
Yeah.
I can uh,
can't call him back trying to,
oh,
maybe he's calling,
you know.
Oh Man,
I got to let the Schnitzel out.
You do.
I think she has to go potty.
Go potty too.
Cause I hydrate so much.
Well these you just at least get,
yeah,
she's standing up.
Walking.
Yeah.
Hello.
Hey,
what happened there?
I just a the soft phones.
Okay.
Oh really?
Are you sure you didn't accidentally hang up?
No,
no,
no.
I'm just,
I'm,
I'm laying down a sudden.
I am laying down.
Yeah,
I'm going to shut up.
No,
no,
it's fine.
It's fine.
Um,
okay,
well look,
uh,
oh by the way,
I know you have a travel day coming up.
You know,
travel days are really,
I travel a lot and it can really affect your,
your bowel movements.
So just make sure you,
it does.
Oh,
You know,
I have to tell you.
It does.
Yeah.
When I'm traveling and the trouble is,
is that um,
you know,
I'm hitting the road and go to the airport tomorrow at eight o'clock,
which is really normal bomb normal bombs away time is eight 30.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I'll be in the car so that just,
it just plugs you up the hallway and then you got to get another car and scratch
dinner.
And so I probably won't do my first load job tomorrow night.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
That's going to be something.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yes.
The smell.
I'll alcohol do back to back loads probably in the evening.
Okay,
cool.
Come on buddy.
Let me know how it goes.
Okay.
I love you.
I'll let you know.
I do.
Love you.
Bye.
Yeah,
unreal.
Come on guys.
Let's go.
Yeah,
we're back.
How was the doctor and my water?
Yeah.
Well a Schnitzel had their shit twice.
That was an intense time of her.
No,
please don't drink at all.
Just a set for me.
That is not just a sip for you.
You're such a liar.
She took two dumps in the grass.
It was 40 of your sips left.
Yup.
I look,
biggest sip of your life just went down.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's bullshit.
She had the ship pretty bad,
so yeah,
she does.
She's usually stupid and she'll just go in.
The sprinklers are on,
you know.
Yeah.
She actually waited for them to be,
to be finished,
which is a first,
it's good.
She comes back.
So good job.
Um,
how amazing was that called top dog?
I loved when he's like,
you can't make it rain with double pipes,
which is true.
That's the whole essence of it.
It's,
it's special.
It's rare because out of respect we got to do this.
Hey Buddy.
Stop Dog.
Right Kate,
buddy.
Stop Dog.
Hey Buddy.
Do you need to wipe down?
Stop Dog.
Now,
did you talk to him yesterday on Father's Day?
Briefly.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
It was brief.
What did he do?
What?
Go to the movies with your mom?
My mom and my aunt flew back from payroll,
so,
right,
so he was alone that whole time.
Was that your mom?
They were gone for 10 days.
What does he do without her?
Nothing.
Right.
He was like,
you're like me.
Stares at the ceiling.
Doesn't like forgets to eat.
Why is that with men?
If the wife leaves,
they just there.
They stopped and they stopped counting on you,
man.
What do you think?
Stay up all night.
Yeah.
For me,
I go to bed at like four 30 every night that you're gone.
I'm like,
blah,
blah.
I just ate.
Well,
we had in the snack drawers.
No meals.
No.
I think we put a little order in your life,
but when you leave I fly off the rails too,
you know,
not behaviorally.
I just get really like I don't know what to do right now.
I just feel like you're,
you're my,
you're my left side.
You're at my other pair of,
we share a pair of jeans.
It's like how I do not go to bed when you're gone.
I don't split.
You have to wake up with Lj.
I mean it's better now,
but when he before him,
Oh,
you never did completely.
I was like,
it's 5:00 AM I should really just turn it in.
She'll like that.
What were you doing?
Watching TV?
Watching movies and just like forcing,
like feeling tired,
like fight through it.
Right.
I remember those days before I kid.
When you get to stay up all night and then just sleep next day.
I know to stay in bed.
Tozer over,
go to brunch.
Yeah.
It's not going to happen for a minute son.
Now I fly off the rails too.
I just,
I don't know what to do with myself,
you know,
cause you're the left leg and my jeans and when you're not here,
I'm like,
I don't know.
I do.
I had to hopping around on one leg,
you know,
it feels sucks.
I feel as jeans,
mummy your mind.
This is how I feel when,
uh,
when you're not around.
I called up inside her,
I called.
I'm excited.
He's
so happy that I'm done.
No,
no.
American announcer does anything even close to that.
I know.
Basically Dick Vitale probably would be the guy,
right?
That is,
does he do,
what's his sound?
He just really,
he is so high energy did he talks himself out of breath and he's,
yeah,
baby.
It's always baby,
but he's like screaming it.
He gets really hype about it.
So people that that are,
you know,
he definitely adds enthusiasm,
but it could definitely wear you out.
Um,
it's a,
it's a lot.
It's definitely a lot.
Um,
wow.
This is a,
that's Italian,
right?
Yeah.
This is,
yeah.
Yeah.
This is this deadly for sure.
Um,
I can't even imagine getting this excited about soccer.
Well,
just,
yeah,
I like enthusiastic announcers,
but it's just crazy to,
to be like that,
right?
Like,
yes,
cause night for American football.
I'll give you a,
with what he's said,
another guy in
ESPN now to dig by cow clearly gets carried away with his word God is going to
be,
that's fine.
Yeah.
That's still within reason.
Now.
It's within reason.
Are you serious,
baby?
Awesome baby.
He's,
he's,
you know,
he's exciting.
Americans are very contained though.
This says a Dick Vitale.
It goes crazy here.
Haley newspapers that cover this program.
Why
weird here?
He,
that's good.
That's not no worries.
Italian
Europeans really loved their soccer.
They go really nuts.
Everyone does.
Arabs love it.
The a rams.
The Latins
nameless.
Well anyways,
so that was exciting.
Got It.
Yeah,
he was fine.
You got it.
Yeah.
Awesome baby.
That's him.
Yeah.
Um,
this guy though,
cause there's also the,
uh,
the Spanish goal guy.
I liked that guy.
Yeah.
Um,
but every guy has got to find their hook.
These announcers.
Right.
You gotta Find Your special book.
Yeah.
Yours would be far,
far,
far apart,
baby.
That's not what I would do.
Um,
let's see.
Uh,
The Spanish.
You don't fart into the mic anymore.
Like he used to.
I did.
Used to do that.
Actually.
I did it in a really,
in a classic jeans episode cause we used to have handheld mics back in silver
lake.
It's not like we're normal.
That one.
I wanted to have one point.
Oh my God.
I wanted to have one get picked up on the audio.
I can't believe you.
Let me just describe,
Oh my God,
I'm a throw up faith.
That's awesome.
Oh,
so fucking terrible.
It.
What does this smelly,
I'm going to throw up.
Oh,
Mike,
I'm going to throw up.
It smells like yoga.
Like those Japanese dumplings we had baby.
That's Rad.
Oh,
oh.
I like that you,
you went like,
this is what marriage is.
You're pushing it away with,
oh my God.
Did you shit today.
That's so you.
And I was like,
who?
Savannah.
And they're like,
she's one of the cohosts.
Oh my gosh.
I could go to a separate room.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
I go into a separate room
and I,
uh,
he said it's me in the scroll in the scrolls are fucking absolute moron.
Please try to ignore it.
That's the best part was he
will keep playing it.
But that's the clip.
That's not the whole thing.
No,
I know,
but that's the clip.
I have it.
But that was a horrible,
and then what happened was Burt,
you and I were podcasting,
you farted and then Bert kept telling the stupid Savannah story and I was like,
are you not going to address?
Which just happened?
Yeah,
because we were in burgs man cave where you can taste it.
It's like coming into my mouth.
We were in his man cave in,
you're fart.
Just,
yeah.
It was a black cloud in that room and I had
to get out there like she's one of the cohosts and so I go on my separate,
oh my God.
I go into a separate room.
That one I remember the smell of.
That's funny you bring this up because I remember that smell.
I had to leave the room.
I walked out of that podcast,
remember?
Oh yeah,
I believe that was one of those.
You were like,
because you smelled it.
Unreal.
Your farts.
I had a fart this morning when I was opening the dog crates and you are my God.
You didn't even acknowledge it.
I remember it was so long and loud.
It was good.
You didn't acknowledge it though.
I was trying to sleep,
but I acknowledge it.
Can you do that now for me?
Can you give me what I deserve?
Pretty Great.
Appreciate
you really dropped some weight on me.
It just keeps telling the Savannah story
why he chose,
he chose to ignore you like a toddler.
Like Ah,
I just ignore that bad behavior.
Unreal.
Have you had any good public farts lately?
I think good public parks it on the plane Lailey far whenever you played.
I know you'd see I,
he's still,
you know,
and sometimes I lift up the best kind is when you um,
when you're trying to disguise it,
you know,
like you need to lift up.
We don't want to go so,
so I'll be like,
I'll be like,
I'll look in the seat back pocket
part there,
act like the straps are kind of fucked up.
Oh God.
As I put it back together,
you know,
that's interesting.
I just usually have a blanket over my lap so I just,
and shop that way and I feel like that kid who cross your legs
pull the leg up.
But I usually lean against the window.
I thought naturally up though,
right?
I thought it would be the input higher flight here next to me,
the guy,
it's a morning flight early morning.
That's first people are,
it's not just far be,
it's also body fluid city.
Like it's everything.
So the guy next to me,
every five minutes for a four hour flight went
like clearing his sinuses and then behind the guy went
and I was like,
wow.
I just kept hearing you being like fucking disgusting.
Well don't get on the plane aids monkey if you're going to spread it like that.
What's wrong with you?
What's wrong with y'all?
I mean don't,
don't spread your disease peg.
I agree.
That's sucking in the snot thing really
gets me.
Yeah.
I that is my absolute least favorite.
I just hate human beings on airplanes and everything.
Everyone does annoys the shit out of me.
No,
I know.
Hate everybody.
It's been really nice not traveling as much with the baby jeans.
I,
you know,
I think it took that to,
to make me slow down.
Yeah.
I am so much happier now that I don't deal with humanity coming up this week.
Oh Jeez.
Fart sparks Capone
early flight.
It's going to hurt your stomach big time.
Now did you fart next to Jill Scott?
No.
He had some respect for that shit on that flight though,
which I hated.
Really?
Shitting on planes.
It's the worst yet I had to now have you chose God doesn't like salmon.
I'm sorry,
what?
Jill?
Scott doesn't like salmon.
I don't think he said that word right.
I don't know what you're talking to Salomon.
Yeah.
She wasn't like it.
I discovered that.
It's interesting was it was kind of how the conversation started and actually
why you're ordering lunch.
Yeah.
And they said,
um,
would you like something or salad with Salomon?
Well,
Hannah,
and she was like,
ah.
Right.
And then it started,
we just started talking.
Well,
I wouldn't eat plain airplane Salmon Saulman to save my duck.
Right.
It's disgusting.
What airline was this?
A Delta?
Yeah.
Even they have g decent meals.
I wouldn't touch it.
What?
I was encouraging her to go to a French restaurant and get traditional salmon
French made where,
I'm sorry,
French Solomon Solomon.
They have,
you know,
basically it's rich.
Medium rare,
but yes,
you know,
they'll take you in the spoon on the piping hot butter and drizzle it so you
have an outside that's kind of lightly fried basically with butter.
But I would be careful with the rare Saulman because you had that in Vegas and
it made you really ill.
But I don't think it was rare Salomon as much as I just got,
I mean,
I don't get rare Salomon.
Yeah,
just medium rare I think is the best way to have.
I don't like that.
I get scared.
I get really nervous.
So it's too raw salmon.
Yeah,
because you don't,
it's not Sushi grade,
it's just some pieces.
Wellman.
I wouldn't do that.
That's just,
you know,
Fridays.
Fridays I'm saying though,
but if you go to like a high end place where it's quality stuff,
I do it that way.
Yeah,
sure.
Okay.
Difference between you and me.
Different strokes for the same folks.
Everyone's the same.
I got another voicemail from the Persian lady.
You did.
We should play that.
So it's just,
it just never ends.
Just essentially the Salamay continues.
That's a,
let's say
this is the latest Salah,
my voicemail
Saturday imagery.
Oh my God.
[inaudible] knock on wood.
Knock on wood.
You're not going there.
Up there are those.
Oh,
I got to tell Angelo
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] agenda.
Okay.
Oh,
long voicemail.
And I know she's never like hit me back.
It's always like,
let me tell you what's going on in my life and this voicemail.
Maybe.
Maybe it's a diary like,
Hey,
Hitler.
Lincoln.
Yeah.
Like it's just kind of her version of,
of luck.
Right?
She just calls it,
right.
Yeah.
[inaudible] was a misery users.
What is Sallie Mae?
Is this lady's nickname for Hitler?
No,
these are all for Hitler.
I just,
I call it affectionately.
Call Him Sammy.
Sammy likes youtube.
Any likes?
Voicemails.
Wow.
Yeah.
Solomon [inaudible] with that a little bit.
Okay.
Bye.
We did season four of the Americans now and last night I was very upset and I
got to say what happened?
But I'm still upset about it.
Either watch a show and then the next day you're fucking upset.
Wait,
did you just give away what happened?
No,
I didn't say what it was,
but one of my favorite.
Oh yeah,
there's,
yeah.
Something bad happened to them and I'm very upset.
Yeah.
That's good.
That's series is so good.
Oh my goodness.
His favorite.
So good.
Yeah.
Orange is the new black.
I know you've probably been watched all of those.
No,
I mean,
it's a great show,
but I haven't,
and we haven't watched blood farts because we're tied into this show.
Yeah.
We got to emotionally wrap it up with the Americans before we can start on the
other.
I'm excited.
I've heard amazing things about the new season of blood parts,
so have I.
Yeah.
He knew they weren't going to fuck that up.
I felt like that,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
I can't wait dude.
It's going to be great.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
Um,
what else do I have for you?
I have something else here.
Oh,
you know,
we,
we haven't done any,
no,
I'm saying the account in a while,
but we do have a,
you feel me count the Cayman for designer.
You know who that is?
Um,
he's wrapper.
Ponder,
ponder upon it.
God Damn it's,
so this is him in the interview on the radio that can check out his,
you feel me?
Is Our [inaudible] okay.
They're on top of each other and grow.
It's really impressive.
Hmm.
So hmm.
Oh Carrie.
I think as far as you feel me,
cause I know you always like to make the distinction between,
you know,
you know what I'm saying?
You feel that there's different categories.
Yeah.
So this one is definitely on.
You feel me?
It's,
it's,
it's really up there.
Okay.
We did it all start for you.
I mean music wise,
I know I read on Wikipedia that you,
you and the church choir and stuff like that and the age 14 you started rhyming.
That's correct.
Oh the odd is it didn't say you put me at 14
you probably haven't really changed my life over.
And you get all that street moved here when I got to her.
What?
Yeah,
I didn't even understand what he said.
Well I could translate.
Yeah,
there's so much going on there.
Well the guy is definitely an island guy here.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Could you do his accent please?
Stop fee.
I mean music wise,
I know I read on Wikipedia that you,
you were in the church choir.
Yup.
It's an easy one.
You can do this.
I read on the Wikipedia.
Did you and the church choir?
I feel like he's a,
you didn't even try on that one.
I know I didn't try it again.
Hold on.
Coffee.
I mean music wise,
I know I read on Wikipedia that you,
you and the church choir a read on the Wikipedia is you and the church choir.
I was good.
That was good.
So yeah,
I feel like he's like British island.
He though,
right?
Like he's island island.
That's an interesting one.
When I,
where the hell is designer from?
Cause his actions also I don't understand if we can get is fuck out.
This guy's from New York and he talks like this.
Okay.
What am it is happening.
He sounds like he's from an like the West indies or something.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Oh,
I didn't,
I did not understand.
I heard some.
You feel me?
I did hear you feel,
oh my God.
Did you hear you feel me?
Yeah.
Yeah,
he's from Brooklyn.
What uh,
what part do you know where this was?
Jesus.
He's 19 years kidding.
Yeah.
I'm from the west Indian part of,
you know what radio show this was taken from?
No,
I think it has some UK and if it,
he's in London right now,
so this is okay.
Oh,
master vaccines you tell us.
You feel me?
Is,
we're just out of that was out of his mind.
So people that don't know about do or die bed Stuy,
Brooklyn.
Yeah.
Real quick for me people real quick,
real quick for this.
I like this.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's really not there for me to know.
When you got it,
you got to really like know how to survive.
It's a jungle out there.
You bumps,
they're like a lot of hustling is every day.
You just gotta grind everybody out there on the ground and I tried to believe
Deb or before
I hear you man.
So he's got that real lazy flow,
you know like that
what was going on for a designer.
I will be going over design things that of still brown and does,
I was out here grinding.
You phoned me doing this thing,
cooking up,
going in the streets.
You me like you know doing his dad tried to book for doing everything like that
would just meet every day for me in the studio.
Man.
You feel me a lot.
Are you filming?
Yeah,
he's cute though.
He's sweet.
Yeah.
Looks a kid.
Let's see those you'll see as your feelings together.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
for me like you know what I'm saying?
That's unbelievable.
That's the best is that dude dropped one in there.
Yeah,
I do know what you're saying and I know what the fuck you mean.
One thing I do have in common with designer is that he was hydrating and he had,
did you see that you are much closer to designer then you realize very,
very true.
What is that song about the panda?
Panda.
Panda on when he got broads in Atlanta.
That's all I know.
But what's the,
what does the credit cards and the scanners,
but what is panda?
Panda.
But what does fuck does this mean?
I don't know.
Let's look it up,
but that's what
you're in your twenties
Oh,
you're right.
It's totally what it is.
Huh?
Wow.
So that's what he's actually saying in that thing.
It's a car that he likes a BMW.
I got broads in Atlanta
credit cards and the scanners hit enough links in the band of black x six
fandom.
White x six looks like a panda.
That's kind of fun going out like I'm on kind a hundred killers.
100 hammers,
black x six phantom white x six panda pocket.
Swole.
Danny selling bars.
Candy.
Oh Man.
I'm the macho like Randy.
Tropical Oscar for grammy.
All right.
I see what all the kids are talking about and I like him.
They must have sent him a few of them after that.
They were like,
excellent song designer.
You got to start writing bits about cars,
Tommy Lamborghini's and stuff.
Yeah,
you're right.
When you did your first 48 bit,
those people sent us a bunch of swag.
They were the coolest.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Okay.
There you go.
There's your panda
look upon upon as funny.
It's a weird like diction that he has for it though.
It's interesting.
Definitely a pot thought it's a potluck.
I shit duck call.
It looks like.
Yeah,
you're right.
What are you talking about?
Not like I just hit it.
I'm feeling a little fun
though,
Huh?
Yeah,
and he said it to somebody else who was high.
I was like,
you need to make that song.
Yeah,
for sure.
I like Rihanna is work,
work,
work.
That was,
that was orchestrated by the man.
The man sex with me.
Oh,
police.
Yeah,
that really fun.
Nice dupes.
Other dumb shit.
Are you listening to now?
Once a but you're done.
Shit,
passion man.
Seriously.
What do you would dump?
Should he listen to you right now?
Tell you who I just got,
I got really into this weekend again.
Uh,
digital underground again.
That's okay.
Classics.
Yeah.
So I was really into humpty dance.
Yeah,
same song.
I played that a lot this weekend.
I know that town you do all around the,
well,
it's the same song.
It sounds just like him.
And he looked just like,
all right,
got the nose.
My name is [inaudible] Auntie,
I'm at the dumpty please.
Okay ladies,
allow me to hop the
July man.
That's it guys.
A good man.
I like that design.
You know,
I know that shit back when you on TV raps was on.
That's the kind of shit that's what they played.
That's the only reason I know that.
It's great to be wraps as good.
Yeah.
Good for you.
I'm really proud of you.
That sounds like good shit.
Yeah,
thanks man.
You got it.
Appreciate you man.
And I appreciate it.
I appreciate that.
Uh,
cause he does not like that song.
The van,
the world saying that's a good number.
What happened to those guys and that thing,
stuff like that.
It's everything.
They don't have aids.
The digital underground,
they probably do actually.
They're all good banging people in the 80s was their whole thing.
Banging.
Banging was like their hook.
Yeah.
So it was two live crew.
Those guys all have these to the,
they were the west coast version of,
they were a little cleaner though.
Then the digital underground was way cleaner and then to live,
my God check was just nasty,
nasty,
you know,
digital.
The ground was like whatever.
I get around.
Well you gotta know the looks like a pickle and you're like,
whoa,
that's crazy for three and a burger king.
Yeah.
It was all,
they didn't metaphors and stuff and two live crew was like face down ass.
That's the way I do to Brown.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yes.
That's a two live crew song.
Linkedin is helpful.
Um,
speaking of that,
I got this.
This is great.
What do you think's going on here?
Linkedin ads
cruiser.
Most of you have ever heard he got it.
He just ran the paycheck today,
guys,
just so you know,
it's not a joke.
This isn't a joke.
You're not supposed to have them.
Crows and Ravens are serious fucking pets and they can hurt you.
It's not a joke.
Not a fucking joke.
Okay?
It's not a joke.
So make sure these things are bucking beaks like a steak knife.
That is the exact noise I make when I bite our son on his stomach every night
before his bath.
I bite his stomach and I,
I nibble on his,
on his stomach and I go,
anyways,
ah man,
don't get a pet ravens,
Ravens,
crows give great knob.
Or
that's also true.
That's the term that's the trade off.
Is that Crow Zilla we'll can hurt you are,
and they can also give you a nice neighbor.
So,
uh,
but there's a video of his,
I watched on gag.
Do you tube or he's like days dog trainers.
They got pictures of children hugging golden retrievers.
Don't hug the dog.
The dog doesn't like to be hugged.
That's a human thing.
That's a new thing that I've been hearing a lot about.
There was a research that can a scientists there that dogs don't want to be
hugged.
No,
no,
of course not.
Yeah.
Good job.
Einstein
there.
It's like he's here with us.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Don't say a fucking thing.
All right.
We're not,
we're done
anyways,
so mad at us all the time.
So fucking mad.
I only,
what are we doing?
We're not doing anything.
Well,
no,
fuck off.
You know
what about what he talks about massaging the puppy.
Yeah.
Do you have that one?
Of course I have that one.
No,
that.
Okay.
That's what happened in pet raven is like,
oh yeah.
Serious videos.
Serious videos like massaging or puppies.
Fast Hole,
talking about animal husbandry and put a laugh track in the background.
Like,
oh,
isn't that funny?
I'll fucking dog assholes
now.
This is my dog and hope.
Fuck the shit out of you.
Why?
Oh,
because I love bucking dogs.
I'm just going to take the dog.
Okay,
so funny.
It's so weird that he's has that stuff and then his videos are totally
different.
You know?
I know,
I know.
It's like a,
who's the real,
who's a real Peter know by the way,
just a reminder that that this second bonus episode that came out on Patrion is
hard fucking core.
It really is.
Literally there's milking German tip videos.
It's censored because,
but yeah.
Yeah.
Well now you can sell your hopes up because it's still hard fucking core.
But it's like we had to Harv because of,
you know,
whatever.
But you could audio wise it's still super hard.
Really hard.
Yeah.
We went old school on it.
Yeah,
we did a what was it?
Uh,
come of my face videos afternoon.
I'm a come on my glasses.
Yeah.
Cause I started wearing glasses and people were like,
why don't you do one of those company?
I was when people come here.
Thanks man.
That's scary.
Um,
anyways,
I think that's it guys.
Let's,
um,
let's wrap this up.
Besides the dog's asshole.
You guys,
we love you.
I'm not funny.
Today was a lot of fun.
We have a fun closing song called wise.
So fad,
endless.
This is by m see tight jeans.
Oh,
that's a good name.
So anything else?
Jeans?
Just a reminder,
guys,
if you're forcing those double pipe classics,
uh,
you can't make it rain.
We learned that today.
It's not natural.
It's not natural from top dog.
He's got to let it happen.
I've tried to tell you,
but now hopefully you'll listen to the master.
And it hasn't happened in a couple of years.
So even the master hasn't had one in two years.
Can he can recall the last one?
Yeah.
So don't force them.
It was so amazing.
That was an exempt.
Makes this an all time classic episode for sure.
All right.
Thanks guys.
See you next week.
Tom and Armenian friends.
Tommy
made a sort of day Hashtag Wiseberg so
I got the joke.
He just has a normal way and it's been like three weeks.
So
I mean,
some social media,
Dan Burton,
Chrysler,
that's a nice shirt.
It was so tight.
Servers I to die.
If the spiral
you start showing the cuisine has changed.
Okay.
To find a way to say it.
It sounds
strange.
Shrink.
The thing is that nobody does
that.
Nobody.